how's it goin breath my name is Pierre
and welcome to Friday it's been a wild
rose
I missed you I missed you I'm sorry I'm
not what a side it's not Friday what do
you know about Friday
you know that it's not friendly whatever
doesn't matter we're gonna do dance this
everything and it's gonna be awesome
I still win make a friend out of a
potato and sing to him you don't know
uh-oh you don't know your potato uh-oh
that's what make you petite it's this
everything become a dolphin hey Martha
what kind of noise is the dolphin make
it's this everything do your best
impression of a crazy fangirl is this
everything
I made it back right maybe I will make
it when I make it man
is this everything do origami I should
know how to do a flower I don't think
he's already got me but let me show you
it's a flower
if you like it bro here you want it hey
you can have it just grab it just get it
[ __ ] dance this everything slap your
butt with a banana yellow banana like no
one sees and then I look to the camera
and say baby okay baby fix this
everything shout out your window and say
I love nuts I'm too shy I can't do it
it's this everything do a makeup
tutorial with anything that you can find
in the kitchen so a makeup tutorial I
got some hot sauce to start with them
bad is it to make your red cheeks look
nice and red it's burning it's burning
so yeah that gives you a good red red
cheeks I should not have started with
the hot sauce should I then the next I
like to do is some Nutella I like to
define it you know give it a good also
here between and these are all natural
ingredients and it's really healthy and
if someone was to eat your face you can
be like go ahead
we have banana um I don't really know
what to do with it I like to it's good
for your skin
cupcake also very good for giving a yeah
I like to finish it off with a carrot
and I think you are pretty much ready
for your date these are all natural
products you can reuse them and all you
have to do is so yeah leave a rating
what do you think
and now I'll make more of these this is
vertically base I'll skip a second it's
this everything
phone call hello is this Anthony yes is
your refrigerator running beats this
everything do a parkour video like I had
handsome who's that
mixes everything up with high heels chew
of gum stick French yeah no it's this
everything prank call Toby Turner and at
the end just say I have to poop then
your exotic dance formatting hello hello
this is Stephen is this Toby yeah hey
Stephen
I'm tired I'm tired of your [ __ ] Toby
well it's not gonna stop I don't want to
edit for you anymore
oh I wish you had a choice got a damaged
sorry I have to poop
it's this everything alright brother
I feel like I should end this video
before I kill myself or something
something even worse and this one is
just quickly say I look so pretty with
cheeks thank you so much for being
supportive even though I might not be
have enough time to upload videos I was
checking comments and messages and stuff
like that is really sweet of you bros to
be concerned about me when I'm gone
I'm having so much fun in LA it's been
spinning it's been a blast I everybody
have more time to upload videos these
days I'm gonna try my best you you both
know I always do my best to upload
videos there's no video it just means I
ran out of time so thank you for
understanding stay the best bros in the
world because I know you will
alright hey kiss above it say awesome
worth activate